inciso b para x distinto de 0 expresa f
prima de x como una función definida por
partes en cuenta el valor de x para el
cual f prima de x es igual a menos 3 y
te estarás preguntando por qué hemos
excluido los valores de x igual a cero
porque no calculamos la derivada cuando
x es igual a 0 y esto es porque la
derivada cuando x se aproxima a 0 por la
izquierda es distinta a cuando se
aproxima a 0 por la derecha y es por eso
que excluimos ese valor de x así que
efe prima de x es igual
veamos en la primera rama es 1 - 12 x la
función la derivada de 10 la derivada de
menos 20 x la vida de seno x es cosa de
x entonces la libra de menos 12 no de x
es menos 2 coseno de x
esto es para x menor a cero y para x
mayor a cero luego indicar en otro color
usaremos el naranja
para x mayor a 0 es la derivada de al
menos 4 x
derivada de al menos 4 x es la deriva de
menos 4x que es menos 4 y la idea de al
menos 4 x con respecto a menos 4x
es
a la menos 4 x en ocasiones se dice que
es la derivada de lo de adentro por la
deriva de lo de afuera con respecto a lo
de adentro
y la tenemos menos 4 y al menos 4 x para
x mayor a 0 así hemos dado respuesta a
la primera parte de la pregunta que es
encontrar la derivada como una función
definida por partes
y tomar en cuenta cuando x igual a 0
pues como lo indicamos en un principio
la derivada no está definida cuando x es
igual a 0 hagamos la segunda parte en
cuenta el valor de x para el cual f
prima de x es igual a menos 3 si esto no
fuera una función definida por partes
sería muy fácil la solución porque
establece díaz la ecuación f prima de x
igual a menos 3 y manipular y álgebra
dicamente esto para obtener el valor de
x pero para esta función no sabemos en
cuál de los casos vamos a estar no
sabemos si la x que hace f prima de x
igual a menos 3 es menor a 0 o mayor a 0
algo que podemos hacer es observar estas
funciones un poquito de detalle y darnos
cuenta que coseno de x es una función
acotada con seno de x sólo tiene valores
que van de menos 1 a 1 por lo que menos
2 coseno de x sólo puede ir de menos 2 a
más 2
así es que esto sólo puede ir de menos 2
a 2 y nunca puede ser menos 3 así es que
si algo va a valer menos 3 va a tener
que ser esta parte de la esta parte de
la derivada esta parte de la definición
de la derivada
en esta parte de aquí y esperemos que
haya valores de x mayor a 0 para los
cuales esta parte de aquí es igual a
menos 3 probemos lo tenemos que menos 4
a la menos 4 x tiene que ser igual a
menos 3
dividimos entre menos 4 ambos lados
tenemos entonces a la menos 4x es igual
a menos 3 entre menos 4 tres cuartos
tomamos el logaritmo natural a ambos
lados el gobierno actual de al menos 4 x
es menos 4x igual a logaritmo natural de
tres cuartos para que quede claro lo que
hicimos
ponemos logaritmo natural aquí y
lograremos natural aquí y lo que se
establece aquí es a qué potencia tengo
que elevar y para obtener y a la menos 4
x eso es lo que es el logaritmo natural
obviamente es menos 4x
así es que esta potencia es menos 4x y
tomamos logaritmo natural del lado
derecho dividimos entre menos 4 ambos
lados entonces del lado izquierdo
obtenemos x es igual o podemos decir
también que multiplicamos por menos un
cuarto menos un cuarto logaritmo natural
de x entre 4 tenemos que verificar este
valor de x vamos a verificar aquí para
esta función tenemos que ver que x
cumplen las condiciones para usar esta
función que x es mayor que 0 pero aquí
podemos decir
aquí tenemos un signo menos pero tenemos
que recordar que el logaritmo natural de
tres cuartos es negativo dado que tres
cuartos es un número menor a uno
logaritmo natural de tres cuartos es un
número negativo elevado un exponente
negativo es tres cuartos ahora esta
parte es negativa
- un cuarto también obviamente es
negativo negativo por negativo es
positivo así que el valor de x es
positivo y podemos entonces usar el caso
de x mayor a 0
y por lo tanto esta es nuestra solución
así que x igual a menos un cuarto
logaritmo natural de tres cuartos es
nuestra solución f prima en x es decir f
prima en menos un cuarto logaritmo
natural de tres cuartos es igual a menos